okay hi everyone welcome to this review
of uh wolfram language capabilities
today we are looking further
at new compiler capabilities
and christopher is sharing his screen
and where do we start
so this is sort of what we so the last
time we started talking about this and
then spent a lot of time talking about
down value compilation so we didn't
totally finish this
um
the main thing that that's still left to
discuss though is the the naming
so to you know to review i mean
basically what this is it's in the same
way that dollar pre is basically like
you know conceptually dollar pre is
caught or dollar post let's say is
called on every piece of output but by
default it's just doesn't do anything
you know this is these are various
functions that you know are conceptually
called in various places but most the
time by default don't do anything
um
and in the same way as dollar post
there's pretty much no reason why the
user should ever call dollar post um
it's only really useful to define
so that's basically what these are
um okay so dollar post is a creature of
the main loop
so what is the analog of the main loop
here
well it's it's
yeah i mean it's uh okay they're their
various analogs so in this case of on
free this happens this is the memory
management system so that that's
checking the reference counts or in the
case of to and from expression although
these names might change this is the the
system that creates the the wrapper code
that is like the glue between
the evaluator and compiled data types
and and so on so but is that there
what is it going to
so that to expression means it's coming
from
what in the compiler
it means that maybe
right i have some compiled type that's
you know who knows what it represents as
struct in c that's interacting with some
external thing or you know god only
knows what it is and it's represented in
some low-level way that you know and and
i basically but but for the purposes of
compiled code functions you'd like to be
able to serialize that to an expression
and deserialize it from an expression
so so by default you know when i call
compiled code function
it it creates it compiles the main
function and it also compiles this
wrapper that does that serialization and
so these are the functions that tell it
how to do that serialization for you
know user-defined types
but
what i mean you said it might be
two-expression
but what would it be fed i mean
two-expression would normally be fed a
string
right so that that's why i'm okay so
ignore the right-hand side of these
arrows here right i mean this is this is
me sort of saying that as an alternative
i think that the easiest thing to do
would be to have this thing called
compiler interface
as an alternative in some cases there
might be some top-level functions that
you could define instead but i think
this is kind of a bad idea and in some
cases there's no top-level equivalent
that you would you know
you try and these are all puns like this
is not actually to expression this is
something that's a little bit like to
expression and so on so
everywhere
calling it compiler hook or something
well that's that's sort of the question
so okay hook is another term
um
compiler hook yeah
it's a bit like captain hook
yes
um
well
i mean
okay
so
again can we get some sense of what the
different um
event types are for the hook
you've got on free
yeah i mean i can
maybe maybe tom can think of some some
yeah i mean there might be some other
ones like
you know shut down the compiler or
um shut down the
this particular segment of code
or or load the compiler or something is
another way like there are various
libraries there are lots of external
libraries where you know uh when you
first
uh you know when you first load it you
need to call some init function for
instance okay so wait a second so this
is
okay so hold on a second what declares
this this is
this is when anything is freed
so somewhere inside the compiler
it's calling something
it's always wrapping compiler interface
of
i mean
okay if you write the code there's
something that is
doing the freeing that it would normally
do
and then so in this case what it really
is it's like if i say
you know
so so let's say you know this one two
three let's say that's a packed array or
something you know it's some memory
managed thing okay
um or or it could be user defined type
more realistically be user defined type
if i say a foo
plus two and then i call four you know
something like that right so this foo
doesn't get returned from this module
the point is at some point you know
after
after this line
this foo is going to be you know is
going to be freed because it's not used
anywhere what's the specific call that's
going to be made then so it's going to
be compiler hook of on free of it's
going to be either there's you know
there's going to be an interesting
function
right that that'll be something like
this right you just click the function
you never call this expect you just
declare the function no i i'm aware i
understand that i'm asking this is i'm
asking what is the thing that it would
be doing if it were doing it explicitly
yes this is this is invisibly what what
secretly happened right it would be a
null function that turns and that does
nothing a function with no body that
gets inlined but how does it what does
it pass the foo there
if you would pass the if you pass it you
pass a reference to foo that then you
could you can then operate on so like
let's say foo holds uh let's say you're
doing some sort of network thing and
you're holding you know a socket
then
you would need to write an on free
that closes the socket correct okay so
the on free
will have something that is not just a
single on free
but it'll be something that is an on
free for this type and on free for that
type exactly exactly exactly yes okay
for all of these okay but but wait a
second so compiler interface oh i see so
when you define the function when you
define the function you'll write a
function declaration and you'll write
that let me write one of these for on
free
you'll you'll write you know you'll give
it a type and you'll say something like
this you'll say okay the type of this
function i'm writing it's going to have
type you know it's going to be a
web socket
yeah uh you know and then it returns
null presumably
um
and then the body of it is going to do
who knows what
right and so when you know when this
invisible function gets called foo in
this case it's a packed array and it's
going to call the pact array version if
foo were a websocket then it would it
would call this this version right just
because that's how the type system works
but so wait a minute when you give a
function declaration normally
i'm very confused here normally there
will be a function declaration that
would say
the name of a function
and then it would give its body where is
the name of the function yeah that's
that's the name of the function
you're allowed to have compound names
like this
yeah
because you're just associating the
function declaration to this compound
thing but
you could just like it's like this you
could have just call that compiler
interface on free
as a symbol name and then you have a
compiler interface two expression symbol
name and all that but then you know this
is a proliferation of single names this
just makes sense yeah but okay but the
point is that this declaration for on
free is for that specific type and there
could be another declaration for another
type right right and there's probably
some there's probably some generic um
polymorphic
declaration that does the standard thing
whatever it is which is probably a no-op
yeah exactly that's exactly how it is
okay but but are they all no-ops by
default like two expressions shouldn't
be a no-up by default
by default i mean i i think right well
some of them probably something like two
to and from expression probably don't
have defaults so if you try to return a
type that doesn't have that then you
can't return that at the top
because you haven't defined a proper
interface right right and more you know
who knows what the default interface
should be
right the message would say you know i
can't compile this because there's no
implementation of to expression yeah
yeah
or from expression okay okay
okay so i'm i'm slowly understanding
this so then
the thing that is passed in so function
declaration has passed a pure function
whose and the name of this thing is on
free applied to that type
uh
yes i mean this would be
this is where i put my declaration my
code for on three that operates on a
websocket
yep
right right so and this is equivalent to
something like this if you if you you
know
you know that's how the function declare
that's how function declarations work so
this is the function name
these are the arguments
etc
yeah
well or you could say compiler interface
of onfree equals function of blah blah
blah
sure yes that yeah i'm just trying to
make it clear this is the function name
yes
um
okay so hold on so normally a function
declaration
would if it wasn't one of these special
utility
type things what would it normally look
like would it say function declaration
of f comma typed blah blah blah yeah
it's exactly the same
no but
in this case the function name happens
to not be a symbol it happens to be some
bigger expression but otherwise it's
identical and and you can already in
other places you know
you can define function names that that
are not symbols so you can do that
yourself you can you could you could do
this you could invent your whole another
whole thing where you didn't use symbols
you know use one symbol in these strings
if you want yeah sure
it has to be a symbol somewhere so yeah
but yeah
well why does that have to be
because it's still assignments
it's rare that you never you know you'd
never really want to be able to define
you know
two you know two of hello as a function
this is not very useful yeah correct but
you could have a kind of an index a
parameterized collection of functions
you know f of one f of two f of three
all with function declarations
sure i mean this is exactly the same as
what we do with um library function
above where you know you know you'll
call library function of and then you'll
give the name of your your your c
function or like you know
malloc of blah blah blah
right it's exactly the same thing it's a
parametrized set of functions okay okay
but the difference here is
that
from within the compiler it is calling
back into
the on free thing for this particular
type correct yeah there's so to be
precise
when you when you when you declare this
type
there's
by default a bunch of code that's
automatically generated and in the body
of that code like
for the when you know when the object is
freed there's a hook that's going to co
that's going to try to call this
function
right so it's just it's just
automatically generated code that
happens because you declare when you
know when when you declare type product
there's a bunch of code that just gets
what does that decoration look like
type the type declaration one you have
at the top there
uh well we have uh no you drop right
above yourself this one right here yeah
yeah
so what was the question
no so i mean what you're doing there is
that's a type declaration of foo prod
why does it have product as the first
argument
of type declaration
it's a type of kind of declaration that
it is you could also type of type
declaration
yeah
which is usually called a kind but
yeah
kind okay kind of type declaration
um
okay
that's the declaration of the type
and so this function declaration
i mean
couldn't one imagine
function declaration of compiler
interface being its own separate
function
that's called something like you know
compiler interface declaration
that was actually one of the original
designs but i don't think it makes
it's like it's just a convention that's
all and i think you know
i think in this case because there's
nothing different about them they're
just function definitely
a convention is a perfectly reasonable
way to do things
i think this is equivalent to to the
fact that you write dollar post
dollar post equals instead of having a
function that's called like you know
sec
post function or something right yeah
yeah exactly
yeah okay
okay
something like c plus plus you know
really all you're doing is you you know
if you declare a destructor it's just
you're declaring a function that's
delete
it has a slightly funky syntax but it's
just
function declaration what is it syntax
i think it's like you know if your type
is is type t then it's like tilde t is
the name of the function
okay
but so
you've declared a type with type
declaration
but the thing that's confusing me is
this okay
the things you're defining here
are are
are keyed to a type every one of these
two expression from expression on free
these are all type related things
whereas for a given type there could be
a thousand functions that all take these
random types but the thing you're
defining here and the thing that it is
cognitively connected to
is it is the on free declaration or the
two expression declaration for a given
type well kind of i mean but the thing
is
not really not in any way it's different
from a function because first of all
this could be polymorphic so for example
you know i could have one declaration
here that works for several different
types by having a tight union by having
the second one no by having by having
this be a type for all or for all types
yeah if you define like an abstract type
that your concrete types all
uh and you know all implement then you
can you can have like yeah for all type
and then you you know you can have a
conditional that says it's an element of
you know
this
but look when we explain this to people
the way the explanation is going to go
is you set up a type
okay you can define
ways to free things of that type you can
define ways to to you know to serialize
things of that type and so on that's the
way you'll describe it no i think that
the way if you want to know how you
actually document this realistically the
way people will encounter this is
they define a type
um and again this only comes up if you
do the low level way of defining types
you know but most of the time this this
sort of gets most of this gets done
automatically
but you you happen to have a case where
you need to define this lower level type
and then
uh you try and return it from your
function to the evaluator and you get
this message saying basically if you
want to do that you need to define this
function here and that that's how you
find out about it is because at some
point it would try and compile something
that that needs one of these functions
and and there would be an error because
it's not defined
stephen if i can jump in for a second i
think i think you're sort of gravitating
to something like well why don't we put
you know this code in the type
declaration
because it's associated with the type
and i think multiple reasons one of them
is that you can make these um
polymorphic and that doesn't
doesn't do that the other reason is that
all the other kinds of methods that are
associated with the type are implemented
through a function declaration they're
not part of the type i mean if you think
about you know if you think in terms of
classes
you might you know it would be the same
thing why aren't we putting you know
these these
functions in the type declaration
because they're sort of method functions
for the class it's like well we could
have done that but the way our type
system works and the way we've chosen to
do things is more like you know it's not
like
the more c plus way it's just say look
you can define a function that takes
this type and then it does stuff
um
so
what they're doing here is consistent
with how we do every you know how we do
other method functions
for this type these are just specific
conventional ones that you know will be
called at certain times so that you can
use them for certain things
i think it's i think it's consistent
with everything else that's being done
here
okay what do you think they should be
called
in terms of
names that name
yeah like whether it's compiler
interface or compiler hook or
i don't know
it's kind of an auto called function
it's kind of a
i mean call back is
what they are
um
yes well it's a good reason to call them
that
i mean compiler callback has has that
virtue that yes this is something that
some code that the compiler generates is
going to be called by the compiler that
you then de you know that you may define
to give certain behaviors
i mean hook is also good because it's
also sort of it could be
because it's not necessary it's the
compiled code not the compiler itself
so it's not connected to the life cycle
of the compiler
yeah that's true you're not you're not
doing you're not affecting the compo
you're not affecting other compilation
with this you're you're right it's a
runtime hook so right so runtime yeah
you're defining other code that will be
called at runtime that's
was
auto-generate you know the compiler
auto-generated code
with these callbacks in them and now
you're providing the callbacks if you
want right so this is the thing from
within compiled code
that it is
a function
within compiled code that's being called
okay how about just type in another name
compiler called function
many functions are called yeah yeah
that's that's what the compiler does is
it calls functions
yes i think that's confusing because you
may you may be using some whole set of
functions somebody else has written and
your function just happens to be calling
that
okay
okay so that's i mean i think i think
the callback is nice because i mean hook
you know has hook kind of sounds like it
could mean many things yeah because
you know
and an interface is is also a little bit
vague because it could because those you
know interfaces are a thing and lots of
components okay so compiler callback
will be the name then
compiler callback
so this is declaring
i'm not sure i think
that's that's okay
which compiler callback yeah yeah that's
i i would like that
it's a callback used by the compiler
not necessarily at compile time but you
know yeah yeah i i think that was fine i
mean how about i just i'm just i don't
know whether we have the word code any
of these things but
compiled code callback
it could have that as well
uh i'm not i'm not sure about that the
only place where code is used right now
is in the compiled code function
and actually does what
that's the interface from the
it's the object that gets returned by
function compile right just write that
down for a second because that's compil
by function compile compile code
function
is a function called by the outside
world that goes into the compiler this
is another part of the sandwich so to
speak this is a function that is the
opposite of that is a function called by
the compiler into the outside world
i don't think it really has anything to
do with the compiled code function and
it doesn't i know symmetry with compiled
code function either
yeah but okay but i mean it's it's a
this is i think it's called compiled
code function because i'm not sure what
compile returns but i think it's just
it's trying to dodge the name of
whatever compiler returns this returns a
compiled function that's why it's called
a compiled code function actually
okay
i think compiler callback is the least
least unbelievably confusing of the
things we have
fine
um
[Music]
okay now what about the names like on
free
i'm not sure all these example names i
think are are
very tentative yeah because i mean this
preposition like on free is very
different from two expression
sure and i think this could be something
like
you know expression serialize or
expression d serialize and stuff like
that might be a little bit more clear
especially because this one has a pond
to expression and and so on so
yeah i mean these names are not right
but but i think these are
these are kind of easier well serialized
to expression serialize you know
boy yeah okay okay okay i get it
that looks good okay all right so right
now those are the only three that exist
of these
uh
callbacks
yeah i'll actually i'll have to survey
things a bit because i think that
they're i mean so right now none of
these exist right now there are
functions with names like compile
backtick you know on delete overload
blah blah blah and stuff like that
so i i you know i will need to survey
which of those existing which are
actually worth having
but i think i think three of these is is
the main ones that i can think of so
yeah these are the 3i routine encounter
um okay
okay what's next
okay so this is i i've reordered things
a little bit because otherwise we're
there's some topics we won't get to that
we should
so basically this is this is about
i'm not sure i completely understand
what we're talking about here actually
so i just wonder if it's not a bit
premature to talk to
go through this
maybe okay
i guess we could we could we could try
and do this next time or something um
i just would like another round of going
through this with with you actually
maybe tomorrow um
yeah okay sure well let's let's see i
mean i think we'll we probably will have
to have one more of these so if we will
then then that could be the thing okay
so i guess the next thing is is
the thing that that's going to eat up
a lot of time which is expressions
um
so basically you know as discussed
several times before
expressions
right now in the compiler behave very
differently than they do in the top
level
um
and right and so probably
eventually you probably want to have
so i think the thing to do right now is
just that
we'll have some type
that's kind of expression-like and can
get converted to and from expressions
but which is kind of like some sort of
held expression or raw expression
um
and this is an expression which
basically nothing happens unless you
call eval it's the same as the extra
type it's literally the same as the
extra type in mc code steven which okay
right which means it does nothing i mean
the point is that that normally
expressions in the wild
like i'm going to give a physics analogy
but i want but i mean expressions in the
wild are continually being
being you know they're being continually
being evolved
and these are expressions which are
not
you know
they're just really structural
expressions and they're not eval is
nowhere to be seen
unless you explicitly call it and you
can call eval on them so
right so this is one of the questions so
the basic i think that the the two main
questions are how do you make these how
do you create one of these expressions
and and how do you uh like what's the
syntax for it and how do you evaluate
them
so i mean the the way it works right now
you know internally in the compilers
there's some construct called you know
constant expression or something like
that
that you know
you give it an expert and then that
represents you know it'll interpret that
as one of these held expression things
and then if you want to evaluate it you
know you call some internal function
called evaluate
so i guess that the question is what
would be this outer thing
okay
you create some one of these from
other expressions in the program so the
constant expression is just make an
expression that is literally that the
argument okay so just just to zoom out
for what causes an expression in the
wild to be evolved the answer is it has
symbols that are in the symbol table and
have things associated with them
if those symbols
were not in the symbol table or didn't
have anything associated with them the
thing would just sit there
right i mean
the thing that causes the evaluator to
get any traction
is the fact that there are those values
defined so in in principle one can
imagine something a super block
in which
every
uh in which all values are removed from
every symbol so all you have is just the
name of the symbol and it has no values
it has no down code it has no down
values et cetera i i assume that's not
quite if you had a symbol an expression
entirely built of you know strings or
numbers or something the evaluator would
see it would visit every part of it once
but it wouldn't do anything so maybe
that's a detail but
i'm just going to well unless the
evaluate has side effects
i don't know what difference that makes
but the main point is that
the the thing that causes the evaluator
to get traction
is that there are that these named
symbols correct those symbols in there
with names and they do exactly with
names which have other associated you
know
evaluation semantics for them
correct so in a sense
the
you know were we to have kind of some
super block thing that simply switches
off all values for expressions switches
off all things associated with symbols
then we would have
i mean
it's not clear what we could do with
that at the top right because this is
the issue is the fact that you know
right if you had a super block
first of all you wouldn't be able to use
any functions inside of it and second of
all you wouldn't be able to use any
functions outside of it because it would
be you know have head super block or
whatever
yeah that's different from this
okay the problem is as soon as we have
an expression structure that has you
know that has encrustment in it
has some kind of protection against
evaluation in it it does not have the
same structural form as the expression
as the as the inert expression that
you're referring to
right i mean
i would argue you know that you know
based on also you know the previous
discussions about this i mean i would
argue that basically the full sort of
you know mc code expert struct that that
that's available you know in the
compiler there will not be a syntax that
lets you fully emulate that in the top
level um
and so i think that we're probably going
to want to have some expert type in the
compiler that's sort of more
interoperable with the top level
expressions or has behavior that's more
similar
but i think if we want to have this you
know basically the the the mc code
expert
then
i don't think that the the interface for
creating it manipulating etc will be
compatible with the top level
um okay so one possibility is it's like
a thing that's been created in a vacuum
and that's pulled out and put in the air
and it suddenly oxidizes
i mean in a sense
what you're describing is you could
imagine something that is cooked in the
compiled code level as a pure extra
struct and as soon as it's taken out
it's exposed to the air it's oxidized
it's evaluated
that's one possible model
sure yeah
and
the prevention of oxidation
is a difficult matter
i mean at the top level it's difficult
right i mean i guess the the real issue
is just the fact that
that it's
it's sort of very useful that in the
compiler you can do things like call
head
on one of these expressions and you'll
get the head of the expression you won't
get hold or inactivate or i know so so i
mean basically what you're saying is
when the thing comes out into the air so
to speak just like
uh two expression has a third argument
which says how should it come out
because that's another case where two
expression is a is a direct analog of
this i claim of the the pre you know the
expression once it comes out of the
parser is unoxidated so to speak
unoxidized
and then what's going to happen to it
and two expression has that third
argument that says what to do with it to
either protect it or not as it comes out
of its pristine state
okay
do you agree with that claim that it's
similar to expression what has to happen
to expression is making a
a pristine i guess so i mean when it
gets
sure when it gets returned to the top
level but there's also the issue of
evaluating it in the middle of compiled
code i mean if you make it
that's a different thing so
right but i mean once you're doing that
the evaluator is gonna just have at it
every part of that expression it's not
gonna nothing's gonna be held it's just
gonna be like
you know it's it's just the same thing
as if it was returned like from two
expression without a third argument yes
okay
well i i think that that's not an
unreasonable approach that is that in
the compiler you're peeking and poking
at this expression just like you could
peek and poke at a string before you
feed it to two expression
you can do anything you want to a string
it's never going to nothing's going to
blow up it's just that here
okay so so the the intermediate case
would be manipulating an ast in the top
level so claim my claim would be
that perhaps we should provide something
well like we can manipulate boxes but
maybe in addition to a string boxes we
should provide an ast
for for expressions that you can
manipulate i don't know the only the
only difference is the fact that
that if you called head on that ast it
would not return the head of the you
know it would not have been ordinary
no that's correct it would not not
return an ordinary head it would return
it would yes i mean i think
the axt it would return an ast adorned
head
you know i mean there's an ast it has an
ocean overhead it would return the ast
if i'd head yes which might be wrapped
in i mean look but i think the way to
think about this perhaps is
you know within the compiler the things
operating in a vacuum there's no air it
doesn't no no oxidation happens
um as soon as
as soon as well you can either
explicitly puff air at it with the
compiler
or you can return it
like the like the parsed expression of
two expression
and as you return it
whatever is the returning mechanism
should like to
to expression allow some kind of
wrapping at that point
and then the missing functionality would
be
that an alternative thing that you could
do
is to go from the compiler expression
struct
to top level to a top level ast
which you could then manipulate more
conveniently that you can manipulate a
string
but you less conveniently but admitting
that it is not the same thing
as a plain expression
i mean in other words we've been dancing
around the possibility that we could
have a plain expression
that
would
not mean anything where plus has been
switched off
the i think we've danced around that
enough to have decided it's just not
going to work
and that you can micro adorn it with
inactive
you can wrap it with hold
or you can
fully
sort of you know you could fully wrap it
with an activate
or alternatively you could have some ast
type mechanism that has all kinds of
metadata tagging
and we need good interoperability
between the hold representation the
inactive representation and the asd
representation
and then you're talking about is at the
top level top level yes
right and i'm saying that then what
should happen is in the internal code it
is yet a different representation which
is the unoxidated
you know
uh un um
uh raw expression
and
that
these different forms like the ast form
or the held form and so on should be
easily gettable from that as it comes
out of the compiler and things going
into the compiler you should be easily
able to construct this
naked expression form from an ast or
something like that so i think the way
to do that though i mean i think that's
a slightly different question because i
think the way you would do that is just
before you return it you cast this raw
expression or whatever it's called to a
you know expression ast or something
like that and then you return the
expression ast that but that depends on
his idiomatic way of doing it right that
depends on its compiler callback of of
uh you know of
well no i would argue that i would argue
that that you know the expression ast
you know data you know type of course
that has its own compiler callback
definition for how it gets serialized
from expression and so on i would argue
if you have a function that that
fundamentally returns a raw expression
and you'd like to you know return this
to the top level as a as a
you know
ast
then the way you would do that is not by
redefining the way that raw expressions
get returned everywhere you would just
call cast on this particular raw
expression convert it to an ast and then
you know
that would have its own callback code
wait a second so what you're saying is
for the compiler within the compiler
there is an expression data type
which is an un which has nothing to do
with the evaluator it's merely
structural right which is why i think i
i think it should have a slightly
different name but yes there's something
within special expression
russian
expression expression
no
expression structure
i'm not sure there's nothing wrong with
calling it expression i mean every other
type okay okay look the thing
the thing is integer 64 doesn't come
with any
risk of evaluation there is no risk of
evaluation for integer 64 because it's a
no op in the evaluator
okay is there a symbol is there a data
type symbol in the compiler
no not at the moment but there could be
so let's think about what that one would
be if we had it
because that's going to have the same
issue as expression
yes
um
see this is why i like to like a name
like like raw or something because you
could have raw symbol raw expression
because here's the concern right right
now this is how expressions work right
now if you write something like you know
yeah
the point is is that we could
you know i think we want to do this in a
way that in the future we could add
something that is more like the
top-level expression
um
you know like for example
based on the way the compiler like
based on the way the compiler works
right now you can't just write two plus
x and have that be interpreted as an
expression as you would in top level
right instead there's going to be need
to be some wrapper that's another thing
that we need to name that's like the
this is a this is an expression literal
if you know if you get what i'm saying
in the same way you need quotes around a
string right
um what the heck is an expression
literal in in what oh you mean no i
don't understand you mean you mean it's
making it closer so what i'm saying is
that like for example suppose i wanted
to do something like
um say you know f is an expression and i
have another expression that's like two
plus x and i'd like to you know i have i
have x
right i isolate expert one equals f
you know expert
two
equals two plus x
and then i wanna say expert one of
expert two right i mean that's something
i could do in the top level and i'm
going to get f of 2 plus x
right
so the point in the compiler
if you write 2 plus x if i write you
know x
2 equals 2 plus x it's going to complain
and say
i you know i don't know what x is i
don't know how to you know i can't do
plus on this thing i don't know what it
is and so on i get it okay so so the
point is is that the way that that i
think you do this right now which is
nice because it means that in the future
we can do
you know
it's compatible with the fact that this
is a different kind of expression than
we have in the top level there's gonna
be some wrapper around here that's you
know some you know
magic compiler expression
of this
and then you're gonna you know this is
going to create this magic compiler
expression object that you're going to
manipulate in all these ways and so on
so in other words you are leveraging the
parser
but that is otherwise is that going to
be is that function going to behold all
well it's usually this isn't compliant
a function function stephen so it's it's
it's held anyway it's in code so it's
held anyway so
this
the big question from before was
should we have a version of this that
has a top level equivalent and i think
the answer we basically come to is that
we cannot make a version of this with
the top level equivalent just it just
doesn't work
um and so
right and so i guess the question is
sort of what should this
i mean one of the questions
but one one thing that should be the
case is that if you take a piece of
compilable code the thing that you gave
as the you know in function compile you
take that function with a typed you know
essentially the typed lambda
and you simply run it through the top
level evaluator it should just work
well i mean we talked about this last in
one two weeks ago most things would just
work but there are some things that
really like like this for instance that
with a lot at least without a lot of
a lot more work basically can't just
work i mean just because of the way that
or like another example is calling if
you call a function from c like the
stuff with library function declaration
if you you define a function that's
going to call malloc right that really
can't just work from the evaluator it's
just not how the evaluator works
if it's going to have a call into c code
if your pure function has a call into c
code
you claim you can't make that work
because
that because it's too interwoven with
the things that
are i if i if i call a function like yes
basically yes like if i if in the middle
of my compiled code i use some low-level
thing to allocate memory on the stack
you know this cannot possibly
can't possibly work doesn't mean
anything right
okay so so i think that i think that in
you know ideally in basic we i think
that the okay i think that
the goal should be that
you know as much stuff in the compiler
we should make it so as much stuff in
the compilers compatible with the
evaluators possible i think that
anything that can be written in some way
in the evaluator should be written in
the same way in the compiler so there
shouldn't ever be you know two competing
ways but inevitably there are going to
be some things that you can only do in
the compiler you know because other i
mean that's part of why the compiler is
useful
right okay but so this is okay i'm i'm
still coming back to this object here
because i can imagine wanting to do a
two string
this is like another thing that two
string might
you know that two plus x
could be
from a string it came out of a parser
you know for example i could imagine a
quite useful case where that was created
by a template
string template expression template
or an expression template
think about the expression template case
because that's a case where the thing is
a is a structurally created expression
that didn't hit the evaluator yet how
does that work i've forgotten how hold
on template expressions when you when
you call template apply it'll evaluate
the template expression
i mean it fills it in and then it
evaluates it right but what i'm saying
is you can imagine a template expression
where it doesn't evaluate it where it
merely structurally creates it
that that will be a useful thing to do
for example in the compiler right so my
question would be
i mean if you look at that look we've
got these different cases we've got two
expression we've got template apply
what else do we have that in a sense
structurally creates an expression
without the immediate need for
evaluation
if you understand what i'm saying yeah i
mean i i'm thinking um
what other constructors do we have we
have deserializers like reading an mx
file or reading from math link that's
not evaluating right
could you write some of these down just
so we know what all of these are
so we've got two
okay
we've got two expressions sure what
these what these are functions
that produce
structural expression expressions
and they produce expressions and there's
a question of whether you'd like them to
be evaluated or not that's kind of the
question right so it's to expression
template apply
uh import
uh what other kinds of things
uh from a bite i'm not totally sure
where where you're going with this
though because i think it's sort of
well what i'm claiming is
i think the most common the most common
place you're going to get these is not
from calling to expression on a string
the most common place you're going to
get this is that you're going to write a
literal like you know in your code
probably okay so write that down as
another case so another case is from the
parser automatically from the parser
right and the point is like for example
on the parser
you know
well
yeah i mean the parts are the way you
specified necessarily from the parser
because you might inject it into a
function where you know using with or
something
you know it might have been created
programmatically and then injected
well no look the other case the other
case of this is
you made it structurally inside
the protection of a hold
and then you want to inject it
without its hold
you constructed it
you know with its uh
you know like a i don't know like that's
the case that's by the way very annoying
to do right now could you write that
case down there
that's annoying independently of the
compiler
that's that's incredibly annoying right
so the general category here is meta
programming and structural creation of
expressions independent of their
evaluation
and
the you know one version of that is
you stored a giant expression in a file
in
wxf in in in text whatever you want to
bring it in as a as a raw expression you
do not want evaluation to happen this
was kind of what we
you know when we were talking about the
wdf format data format
one of the things that was an issue
there is we don't want things to blow up
on on you know on arrival
but there was a specific goal because in
you know if you think you have a data
file and oops it's like the you know the
famous macros and a spreadsheet type
thing you thought you had a a
spreadsheet but actually it has macros
that sing and dance in all kinds of ways
which you don't want
so i i think
the issue though i mean in all these
cases the big question is it's just sort
of a syntax question of
you know when i create this object
you know i need to have some argument
that sort of the thing that gets wrapped
around the object before i return it to
you right basically and the only reason
we have that is because we have several
different ways of of stopping evaluation
right if we had one way of stopping
evaluation
you know you might just have a boolean
that's like should you should you no
because because as soon as you as soon
as you have the expression
explicitly given
you know it will be awesome
the situation with this is pretty
different from the top level because
again where these expressions come from
i think they're either going to come
from it's an input to your function
which comes from the evaluator
eventually but like it's an input to
your function or it's something that
you've typed in as like a literal in the
middle of your your code exactly
xyz yeah that's the from the parser case
look another case that i'd like to point
out is that i could imagine
code look let's say i've got an example
okay let's say you are writing compiled
code to deal with different boolean
functions you've got a whole giant
collection of uni you've got you want to
make optimized code for a thousand
different boolean functions so you write
a template an expression template
that has a slot for a boolean function
in it and you want to run the compiler
for each of those things separately then
that's a case where you are injecting
uh i don't know whether that case is
particularly interesting but i mean that
case
in that case yeah i mean
well maybe that case doesn't really
matter because you could have evaluated
the boolean function in the evaluator
first although
although i can imagine you might not
want that i mean you know you might have
not not p and you don't want law of
excluded middle and you want that to be
answered literally even though we
probably automatically simplify that
i'm just i'm just saying there are cases
where you might want to inject something
okay
no i lost my train of thought though i
mean the point is you've got compilable
code but there is a slot in the middle
of your compilable function that you
want to get from the outside world
is that reason so the way that you
normally do that is just by having an
argument to your function
i know but not if it wants to happen at
compile time
i'm saying you want to separately
um
for each of those boolean expressions so
i'm not actually sure i mean maybe this
is a question for tom i mean when you
use constant expression you know native
back to constant expression right now
if in the expert you write
you know you you write you know dollar
system id or something like that will
that get evaluated at compile time
surely yes
no no no it's hell if it's in a function
it's it's held
no no oh
right you're right yes because you'll
you'll write you'll write your magic
compiled expression will write you know
dollar system id
your dollar system right and then this
is just represents the expression dollar
system and and then this will only be
evaluated when you take this expert to
and either return it to the evaluator or
when you call
you want a way of working with dollar
system
right so can i just
code on different platforms for example
yeah can i understand if this thing was
in the middle of an expression template
would it work i think the answer is yes
you mean the compiled coder and the
evaluator no i mean the evaluator the
evaluator is dealing with the template
apply
and
but it's inserting
the
you know it's pretty much
this construct
this construct i think doesn't really
make any sense in the evaluator like
like we already know i i understand that
i understand it but just write out an
example function compile of something
with the with the
okay template applies is the template
applied in the function compile or
outside oh it's outside the function
compile it is operating on the function
compile okay then then this would work
because you know when you click fix
would work yes function is hold all
complete
i think it will just work
i think it will work because template
apply is a purely structural operation
yeah
i know remember how do you indicate a
slot there
template slot right
okay fine fine
so that will you can apply that whole
thing
to something and it will go into the
template slot
okay
what
get rid of function compile then
function compile adding anything yes
that's the whole point
that's the whole point it doesn't it
doesn't
yeah i mean
right
this is a case where this is meaningful
right it doesn't really matter if the
function compiles inside or out of there
outside of the um the template apply is
the point but it doesn't matter either
way right but you want to do this for
function you know declarations as well
as within function compile directly
sure yeah i mean the function is
important yeah
okay all right so then
then okay so just to understand the
models here so
within
compiled code would you ever want at run
time
okay
run time to expression
there's presumably some way to go from a
string to one of your magic compiler
expressions
how would you do that
so let's say i'm writing code right i
see that so right now i mean
right now
if two expression works i think two
expression does work and i think it just
by default goes to one of these which is
incompatible with how the evaluator
works
probably it should have some third
argument or something
um
it's like you'd write true expression
of
you know
something the obvious thing to do would
have its third argument by default
be an automatic
that is depends on its
evaluation environment
so
well
okay the the issue
the reason i say i think it should be
like this is because if you do it the
other way
then
the problem is that we can never
if we end up adding an expression which
which i'm not sure if we will but i mean
if we end up adding expressions more
compatible with the top level expression
then now two expression does the wrong
thing
right it returns like
the niche
i'm doing low level expression
manipulation object instead of the
the less niche one
okay so
i mean
yeah i understand that but i mean so in
the code
you will be writing so it's okay so this
wrapper
should be able to take
for convenient meta programming
this wrapper should have an easy way
to go
either from
a raw typed expression like two plus x
or from quotes two plus x
or from two plus x's boxes
autumn from two plus x as an ast
all of those
should be easy
for this raw expression wrapper
to process into something which in the
compiled code will be represented as a
raw expression
do you agree
yes although by far the most common
cases i think will be from the parser
and as inputs to the function
as in a symbolic input to the function
that is simply passed through directly i
typed input to the function yeah
of
you know
typed e comma raw expression or whatever
it's called
comma you know
had to be who knows what i'm doing but
right i mean i think this is
this is probably the most common way of
getting expression but like suppose i
wanted to apply f to this expression
here
right so so here's a here's like an
example of a very you know simplified
but typical thing you'd like to do i
have an expression as an input i'd like
to apply f to the expression and
evaluate the result
so the question is how to do that so
so the first kind of um
you know
right i think i think
probably the way you zeroth way you do
that is you'd have your again
you need name for this but you'd have
your your magical compiler expression of
f of e
or actually maybe i should say the
absolute zeroth way to do this because
because this doesn't work the absolute
zeroth way to do this is is this
um
[Music]
but right but this should also work
um
[Music]
wait a minute what is that now again
okay so the of f
yes i get it
right so this is already a raw
expression this is well i'm being
inconsistent with my names here this is
creating a raw expression from this
literal here
and then it's constructing and then and
then how do i evaluate this
this
this is what you'd like to write except
for the fact it's a horrible pun because
evaluate does something completely
different
okay so we need another function here
we need a family of things
we need one that represents an
expression purely structurally
we need one that
basically takes a purely structural
expression and evaluates
right and critically it evaluates it and
unlike release hold release holds takes
a held thing and returns an unheld thing
this is going to evaluate it and return
another
structural expression it's not going to
return a normal expression if you get
what i mean yeah i understand what you
mean so could you just write down so we
need what we might call let's just call
them for now structural expression and
structural evaluate
i think these are i think the structural
word is not great it's not great it's
not great we're not we're not but i just
want to understand what else we need so
then
then
for example
two-stroke two expression
could have a third argument of
structural expression
oh but there's a different limit there's
a different thing we need we need the
encruster
for the top level
no wait wait wait wait wait wait
actually maybe maybe one last word we
need is we need the name of the type
um yes we do but i think that'll fall
out of this okay but hold on we need a
different thing we need the thing
structural expression is what you put in
inside compilable code
to represent to if you just type
structural okay it's more complicated
than this we need structural expression
look listen they're different things it
can take
okay so structural expression
cont has to be able to go from string
it has to be able to go from possible
expression
to us to an internally represented
structural expression it has to go
something like it has to go from a
string
you know like like could you just
understand this this case you can't
you can't you can't do this because this
is itself
uh express right it has to be an
expression
just write down your thing above it
structural expression just say string to
structural expression just another
function called string to structural
expression
i would argue that this should just be
due to expression but yeah perhaps so
but let's just write these down okay
and then we've got
um
okay then i claim there is another
function that is needed
which is the encruster by which i mean
the thing that takes an object that can
be at top level
that
wraps around a structural expression
wraps around a thing okay within
compilable code
when you see structural expression of
two plus x that is a signal to the
compiler that two plus x should be
created as a structural expression and
then just insert it there okay yes but
let's say you extract that whole object
and it has somehow managed to arrive at
top level
as a purely structural expression you
need an encruster to keep the evaluator
from putting its fingers okay
well i i
okay
[Music]
yeah i guess maybe so so and i claim
that's a different function from
structural expression well okay no no so
here's the
i'm not sure how that would manifest
itself as a function right i guess the
part of the question is let's say i have
this raw expression type or structural
expression or whatever you want to call
it i return it to the top level as you
know this code would do imagine i don't
have the evaluate around it right
the question is when it return when it
comes to the the top level
should it just be an expression and then
be evaluated and so on or should it have
some wrapper around it
i think it is more useful if it's just
an expression i agree by default i agree
with you
okay but then the return
just like so you want to have a function
that you apply to it that basically is
like you know
by the way when you get returned have
this weird thing around you i would
argue though that there are two i think
that that's not necessary because there
are many ways of getting around it one
way of getting around it is if we had
some ast type you would just cast this
object to an ast type and then that
would get returned as some ast so you'd
write something like this
cast of blah comma
you know ast
expression
one of the reasons we're having this
difficulty is that in our function in
our typed lambda
we're not defining explicitly the return
type
i mean that's what you're effectively
doing sometimes you do but
you don't always have to
right but the cost is effectively
declaring that is there any other way to
declare it
well there are cases where you can
declare yes in function declarations
and actually in this case here too you
can put the typed around the outside of
the function and you can give it a
return type but if the return type
doesn't match the type in here like if
you tell it you're returning an
expression ast and the internal code is
actually returning a structural
expression it's going to say there's a
type error it will not implicitly cast
it you have to do it yourself
which i think is the right thing because
it's more similar to the right level
anyway but but um but now another thing
you could do though is also if we had a
function for example if we had some
expression ast
structure in the top level we'd
presumably have a function for
constructing it from an expression like
you know like okay imagine that we want
to turn this like a as a tree expression
or something you know that that would be
a type actually but you know the point
is is that we could also just you could
just apply that function to this thing
just say tree expression of this maybe
exactly right and that will return a
tree or or for example we probably want
to have a definition of hold that takes
a raw expression and returns a raw
expression with hold wrapped around it
so you could just do this and it would
return a held expression hold on hang on
hang on though christopher
well in in that case but you you've got
to think about the the sort of binding
of like say local variables in in that
so this whole really have different okay
sure like like if you haven't you really
do have yes
sorry look the question is really this
whether
whether in the compiled code you can
just say hold there to get you know
where you can put the encruster into the
compiled code or whether you have to
have it as a meta thing
specify i'm not sure what you mean by
cruster i mean other than other than
then than writing something like cold or
tree express yeah i'm saying right
that's what i mean by the enclusta i
mean that you would otherwise you would
have a thing which in the inners of the
compiler is a purely structural
expression
it is then released to the air it's
about to oxidize
right and the question is don't let it
oxidize put a wrapper around it but so
that so that as it is as the as the
thing is released to the air the thing
has
something
automatically wrapped around it before
it ever gets out
and that's what i'm describing as the
encruster and my question is
do you put the encruster on
when it's still in the oven or whatever
in the vacuum or whatever it's whatever
wherever it is i would argue yes you
should put it on while in the compiler
because that's i mean it's just very
easy to do that i mean as opposed to
having some weird option to function
compiled that specifies how expressions
are
wrapped right before they return so
next question
structural expression
this thing
that
normally you simply type
two plus x into it
but
um
is it possible like with the template
apply maybe the insertion function
i'm just a little bit unclear
you want to be able to just give it a
string you want to be able to give it
an a i'm not sure you want to be able to
give it a string because again i think
there's two to expression can do that
just as well
it already does yeah
can do what can go from two expression
can go to structural expression
can take a string and turn it into a
structural expression at the top level
when exposed to the evaluator what does
structural expression of two plus x do
if you just write that in the top level
i think it gives you a message
but what does it return
does it just stand about x or just
unevaluated how about i think that's
probably the best it's unevaluated and
and maybe for safety it's it's hold hold
all
well i think that makes sense gotta be
careful about making things hold on
you know i don't think i think that case
is reasonably secure because that case
is actually a meaningless piece of gunk
at top level
right and i'm just saying it could it
could it doesn't have to be all but it
could be hold all just because if if you
ever have something you know
right if one of these is released to the
top level when you wrote it in the
compiler you probably didn't intend for
it to be evaluated or like to be safe
you don't want it right all right i'm
convinced that string to structural
expression is irrelevant okay so i'm i'm
but i'm saying now things like import
should then have a structural expression
uh you know
element
perhaps yeah yeah i think that would be
good i mean right now import
there's no versions
for some reason i never remember how to
do this because i always use import for
wxf files there's a there's a what the
heck is the name of it just pull in a
wxf file
the byte array one or no no no no i'm
just i'm just saying i i write out wxf
files and i read them in but don't we
have a function that specifically does
wxf files i mean i just use import and
export
do you mean
mx for dump saving get i know
wsf
i'd forgotten that function i mean i
just i always use i assume it's
equivalent to
export
to wxf
oh as a biter right
okay i i that's that's why i was you
know
good
um
okay
i see that just returns a bite array
object that's why i don't use it because
i usually i'm trying to put it into a
file
that's why it's false because you know
some randomness in the sampling or
something
yes
uh okay
so
all right so then
okay let's talk about structural
evaluate for a second
that's the thing that's inside the
compiler
structure evaluate
what would that do at top level nothing
i mean maybe
maybe just maybe the structural evaluate
could take one of these structural
expression objects
evaluate its contents and then return
another structural expression object
but yes
okay so let's let's
do the following argument
why is it not the case that structural
expression at the top level gives no
message
it's just inert it's just like hold all
complete
and i guess it could be i guess it could
be and and the only the only discrepancy
between that and the compiler is that
in the compiler
uh
in the compiler there are lots of
functions like head and reverse that are
defined on it
and that don't just do what they
normally do with expressions they go
like one level deeper but in the top
level they won't go
deeper or just do nothing and then
structural evaluate
for the structural expression
could
sort of uh
you know could just
do the obvious thing and return a
structural expression i mean that would
be quite useful i think it's a thing
where because you can imagine building a
structural expression
well how would you build it well maybe i
mean
well
to be analogous and again i'm not sure
we want to like okay i i'm i'm concerned
about trying to sort of
carry this over to the evaluator fully
because i predict that you know as we
already know that constructing one of
these in the evaluator is is pretty
fraught and so if we just sort of
haphazardly yeah okay fair enough
the consistent thing would be something
like structural expression of f
of you know like this is how you
construct them you know as you'd say you
know of
oops uh you know this comma
this this would turn into structural
expression of f of
i don't think we should do that i just
don't think we should do that i think
that's way too horrifying
i think the basic thing is
i think making a top-level version of
this that's sort of similar to the
compiler version
might be useful but also involves like a
vastly higher amount of work
and also it might be a difficult idea
yeah because i mean this is look then
we've got a third mechanism beyond hold
and inactive
a third mechanism for unevaluated
expressions yes
i don't think it's a good idea i think i
think it's enough to just say structural
expression is a creature of the compiler
if you return one to top level it's just
a held gun a pile of gunk
yes
and if you want something different done
to it then say first of it or something
yeah i think that's i think that's good
um
okay so then structural evaluate at
least initially would do essentially
nothing
and um
uh okay now let's talk about the names
yeah that's the big question is the
names i think
okay so let's talk about the name of
structural evaluate
what's the name of the type that's not
unusable
okay
because they should be somewhat
consistent right why not structural
expression quote structural expression i
still think that the word structural is
kind of
yeah it's all it's all streamless
it is meaningless but the whole point is
that this is intended to be meaningless
i think the point of this
raw is better raw is better for the type
i'm not sure raw works with raw evaluate
right or evaluate raw like i feel like
those sound like they'd use me
differently well raw evaluate if you're
applying it to a thing of type raw
expression that makes sense that makes
sense but if you just see the term raw
evaluate i mean i guess it's a little
like this already that when you see the
function name evaluate no everyone has
the you know
the function called evaluate does not do
it all what you'd expect it would based
on itself
um
but i know i was very proud of the fact
that in smp the function smp
was the eval function
i see wow
that was that was never as much of a
success as i thought it would be and
part of the problem is that i mean maybe
something was different enough but like
you know there's no eval function in
mathematica because you know it just
it's just identity no i know i know so
was it an smp i mean it was smp the smp
function had some extra control things
in it
um which were also a bad idea but but
that's that's a different story i mean
we will we will be back to having that
in due course as we think about
multi-threading and all those kinds of
things
um
but any case
so
write down okay so what are the
candidates for so we've got raw
expression as a type
i kind of i'm still i'm sorry i'm still
pushing structural expression
the reason i'm pushing it is that it is
an expression in structure only it says
length of blah blah blah blah the
structure is meaningful
there is no semantics it's purely
syntactic
it's an expression in structure only
it has no
you know
it has been
devoid of semantics
i also worried about raw because somehow
raw
i don't know
i mean raw's a bit vague but i think
structural is also i mean
that these names are taken but just as
easily to behold or held let's say and
you know held expression held struck
held evaluated could be but i think that
that's
you know i mean that one can't you know
it's going from a different way i mean
that's that's saying what you don't do
to it
whereas structural is saying what it is
it is representing the structure but it
is nothing beyond representing the
structure
so it's a glass half full type thing
what other candidates are there well
maybe maybe on that no you could call it
like an expression scaffold or something
yeah actually dan on a livestream
suggest expression skeleton
but it isn't really a skeleton because
the whole thing
the whole thing is there it's not just
the i mean that's why i'm saying
structural expression is
skeleton evaluators too bizarre
yeah that's too bizarre might go with
anatomy plot 3d um right
skeleton evaluators is after you specify
the joint position skeleton evaluate
we'll
put it in those positions for anatomy
static expression
interesting
it's not crazy
that's that's not
that's that's that's interesting
static evaluate is a little bit of an
oxymoron but
yeah but you're going to evaluate static
because in that you're applying the
evaluation to the static
that's true
i don't know i think that's
will be hard for people to understand
particularly when we have a whole world
of dynamic
particularly when we have a function
called dynamic
which has absolutely profoundly nothing
to do with this
all right so what else i mean the thing
that i keep on coming back to is
this represents the expression it hasn't
structure is correct it just doesn't
mean anything
it's been
inert
meaningless expression
actually i like a nerve
i mean it's not meaningless it's inert
it doesn't do anything it just sits
there
and that is a possibility but how does
that relate to inactive and why do we
have any names
do we have any what names that use the
word a nut
um
let's look
we'll look we'll look very far
[Music]
okay fine i think we're okay
i know expression is not terrible
um so then what would it be inert
evaluate
so then the type will be quotes inertia
expression and the r the head would be a
note expression
evaluated number actually is a little
better than another well i don't know
another value it might be better because
of the weird character of the function
evaluate itself yeah yeah
oh those aren't bad
yeah evaluate inert sounds like it's
trying to to
associate itself with evaluate which you
shouldn't right and that's evaluated
sounds more sensible
um
could we avoid the evaluate by by having
you know cast an expression
to expression do the
be documented as evaluated yes but
that's an incredible skill
i mean the big yes i i i thought about
this but then the issue is that we can
only do that if we have this expression
this evaluating expression type which we
don't have right now
and okay
yeah and that's the real problem i think
okay so by the way
if you have a nut expression you can
also have evaluating expression
or evaluation which would arguably be
just the thing that we'd call expression
probably maybe
i think it would be clearer to call it
evaluating expression
or a valuable expression evaluate
evaluating or
um
we don't know how useful it's going to
be christopher we we have really
experimented with i know i mean right
now right now there's really nothing
there's nothing in the compiler right
now that really
like
would really benefit from this but at
the same time it's sort of like for
example if we want to do if we want to
do uh algebra you know for instance if
we want to do
symbolic algebra it's like you kind of
need to have
you know where there's lots of symbolic
expressions running around and
evaluating and stuff like that like you
kind of need to have something let me
ask a question if you return an inert
expression from a okay the types
generated inside the uh the compiled
function
give you an inert expression it's now
returned to top level one
it evaluates
it just evaluates okay so it's a regular
expression it's been
somebody with more uh tom a chemistry
analogy here you you take the thing out
of the oven it's in a vacuum and then
it's uh i mean i have the right analogy
right and then the thing starts to
oxidize when you put it in the air
yeah but
yeah yeah that's that's that's that's
okay but i want another analogy for this
because it's like like as soon as you
take it out of where it's being created
it it you know it
way
immediately
collapses when you observe it
that's way more putting you putting the
you're putting the the salt in the soup
or something
i'm totally confused
i'm just i'm just saying that there's a
thing which during its construction in a
vacuum for example
has you know some structure
but as soon as it is out in the wild
it is always being coated with you know
it's always it's always having something
uh
you know it's it's and that's what
that's the way it's like you're
constructing it at absolute zero or
something and then you heat it up to
room temperature so something starts
going crazy or you get things that are
light sensitive i mean yes that's a good
example right
right good good idea yes okay so this is
like photographic film it's in the dark
room and then it's you know
although
that's called
that's
yeah i mean that's that's reacting well
yes anyway
my point here is
that
you're imagining that there is nothing
to stop it as soon as that function
returns there is no
or you know the only way to encrust it
upon return
is to have encrusted it in the compiled
code by for example saying hold
correct correct
so there's no
converting it to some other type that
that has different you know has
different uh remember we talked about
the you know compiler callback
right like if you converted it to a tree
object yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait on
the
compiler callback are you saying that
that the two expression
method of the compiler callback
okay let's say i'm going to return a
struct of some type okay
yes and
then
you're saying that that callback
is the thing that gets called when the
thing is about to return itself to top
level is that correct
yes okay so its name to expression is
rather a terrible name it's particularly
given what we are
about to serialization well i think
if you call it call it serialization i
would call it it's being returned to top
level
it's like
yeah i mean
it's not quite because you could invoke
it into inside the compiler as well
right and you convert you
generally speaking so yeah
okay my claim would be insofar as the
other thing is called on free this
should be called on return
okay two two points so the first point
is that uh here's an example where it's
not on return there's a thing called
kernel function
um
which is you know if i say kernel
function of you know foo
so here's how you do it
here's how you use kernel function you
say kernel function of foo you tell the
type this takes an integer 64 and an
expression right and it returns an
expression for example okay
when you say expression what do you mean
there do you mean a nut expression
uh i mean inert expression
let's say
okay
so so this is this is all an existing
documented top level thing okay and the
way you use this is that you know here i
have my function and now i applied to
some arguments right yeah well we should
probably put the type into the kernel
function
let's see
well right now this is the syntax for it
right correct i think so so in any case
okay how does it convert this six into
an expression in order to feed it to
this function answer it calls that that
callback above exactly so
calling this a return on return i feel
very bizarre
um
yeah
i think something with serialize is is
better but yeah yeah well yeah but but
hold on it's not serializing but we've
got a bunch of weird background noise um
the
okay
um
it's not serializing it's turning it
into an inertix brush isn't it but
that's
i mean well kind of i mean it's it's
that is what serializing is isn't it i
mean it's taking serializing would also
be really putting it out as a bite array
into a file oh that's serializing to a
bike
i mean serializing i i would say
serializing is just about writing it
into some format from which it can be
you know some kind of inert format from
which it can be deserialized without
losing data that's what i would call a
serialization okay fair enough but
you've always got to define in that
notion of serialization you've got to
define its target
right so it's going to serialize to an
expression right right but then so in
other words
the name would be something like
serialized to expression like
just as you have
on free it would be so we should write
that down
i'll i'll do that up here and then the
other direction
is deserialized from expression or
something i would assume so
serialized to expression
i mean the question is can we get rid of
the prepositions or whatever but
um
well expression serialized would be the
obvious deprepositioned form
an expression deserialize
it's a little bit
anything with that is it obvious which
way round it's going
no i don't think it is obvious i think
that's why that's why the two and fraud
yeah okay fine and probably useful
there's a reason that english has the
first preposition
okay so serialize
okay so what we're saying here is
you scroll down right so we're saying
that would have a serialized to it
serialize deserialize no
a serialized to it
it's got to serialize this it has to
serialize the six to an expression
feed it to the foo evaluated etc the
result is another expression and then it
has to deserialize that but let's say
instead of a returning inert expression
it returns a you know another 64 64.
real 64. sure but it's going to
deserialize it internally inside the
kernel function
well that's in the compiler code that
interfaces that is kernel function
that will deserialize to make it into a
this is very simple this is converting
the inputs to expression
calling the evaluator and then
converting it out i mean that's this is
what it does
yeah i mean you you could write it in
you know it's not that's not like many
lines of code
right
um
okay
all right what else
yeah go ahead
christopher
okay so the next thing
um
all right sure so this is maybe another
another
issue
so
um
yeah okay so so basically
this is the question of
how you this is kind of i i argue this
is a pure naming question
um
so this is
given you've defined some say a product
type
now you want to create an instance of it
right there needs to be some low level
function for
creating an instance of this product
type but i'm sorry when you call it a
product type okay every single time i
refer to it i call it a struct why don't
we just call it a struct
we could
i mean i literally or or at least have
that be an alternate name because every
single time you say product i have to
think what the heck does that mean now
maybe that's one
one form for this
um but it could be could be strapped i
did do i did at one point i did a little
survey where i looked through like
rosetta code or whatever and and and i
did not find a single every function
every uh language that had a keyword
called it struct there were other
languages that didn't have keywords and
you know algebraic data types and they
might in their documentation call it a
record type or something like that but
everyone that had a keyword called it
struct we should just call it struct
because that's what everybody everybody
this level of programming knows it as a
struct
i think scrupps and union go together
better than product and
i mean product and some i i know we
yeah struct and union will be the things
yes i mean i think i maintain union and
product are actually not at all
incompatible because it's the cartesian
product and it's the set union yeah but
that's what i i mean i said it should be
called the direct product of cartesian i
think just product by itself is
confusing i've said that before
okay so i think i think right at that
point
i think you're probably right but at the
same time having a you know type
declaration of cartesian product would
also be enlightened well no i know
that's yeah exactly so i think struct is
great i love struct okay okay fine so
okay so struct so so you've defined a
struct and you'd like to you'd like to
create an instance of it
yep so the question is how do you do
that
um
it creates
an incompiled code in compiled code
so this is a little bit like call and
create data structure but this is lower
level
um
in a couple of ways but that would be
like a new what often will be called new
in in some in systems which have to do
explicit allocation is that right
yeah yeah yes basically i mean like for
example in c plus it's called new um
in uh
yeah
yeah
um
is it always a structure could it be it
could be all kind of it's not always a
structure so there's the two that we
have right now are structs and unions
um how about we can i suggest we call it
new instance or create
instance or is that crazy no that's
crazy we've got things like find
instance and things
create compiled instance
and why is it a compiled object
it's not really an object i'm not sure
it's a compiled object that's one of the
questions his name um i mean that's
really the question is naming
um
so so before we launch the names though
so the other the other case which i
think we need to think more about
because it probably relates to the next
the next item which is kind of a big
topic
um
is
there are some
well
this is a complicated topic that really
needs to go along with this this one
here but basically
there is a model in which we'd like it
to be possible to create certain very
low level data types
um like c arrays and stuff like that um
in which case this would probably be the
function to do that um
but wait a second so this function
you're saying normally foo would be a
predefined will be a type that you have
declared
yes and
it has certain parameters the type has
certain parameters in this case it has
fields and things like this
yes that have been defined
now you're saying a c array
might be something where the only
parameter is the length of the array
for example yeah although doesn't the
cra have to know its base type
so
yes so so basically i think
right so i mean in this case
you can infer it can infer its argument
type you could otherwise you could write
you could write this
if you if you if you wanted to but you
probably wouldn't have to write this
because it could infer the argument type
by the way did we implement the colon
colon bracket thing
i don't think so
okay right but conceptually it's that
yeah
okay what's incompatible between those
two things i mean that is that's just a
in a sense the nothing i mean it's
basically just this is the type this is
the type of the thing you'd like to
create and these are some arguments that
specify how to create it no yeah so
there's no there's no issue with the
payload being different from parametric
arguments though
i'm just bringing this one up because
this is a case where it's not a user
defined function
there's not user find type i mean
and and the the argument structures
could be kind of arbitrary
right
uh
right but okay it doesn't seem
problematic there is another angle on
this is you could create this
with a stack allocation instead of a
heap allocation i mean that's maybe
that's too obscure
but
let's think about that for a second
you're putting this on the stack
well i'm using i'm collecting memory
from the stack so i understand that but
i mean you're
at the level of c code
you would be
just you know that's some kind of
ampersandy type thing you've passed
something in that right
i think no no i think the issue is okay
so it's the way that the way that our
say struct types work right now
is
when i create this food type it's
actually secretly a pointer
and it could secretly be pointer to
memory on the heap or it could secretly
be a pointer to memory on the stack i
think that's good i think that's good
that it's like that right
but so i guess the only reason i think
you really want to have it on the stack
is either a if you have if you've
explicitly disabled automatic memory
management because you know that you
know it's only going to be used in this
function and you think it's more
optimized and b just that it's more
optimized because it doesn't have to do
a heap allocation
um i mean in c right the the way you
declare that you have to declare
you can't have an arbitrary sized array
on the stack you'd have to say int you
know actually now you can and newer
versions of c you can dynamically
allocate on stack and i see what does it
look like is it some kind of a smaller
or something just an array of you can
just do array of x where x is like a
variable
yeah that is passed to the same function
or it'll be obm you know but it's
possible the same function right
i'm not sure what you mean by it's
passed to the same but where did the x
come from yeah i could just write like
it's right you know x equals you know
fibonacci of 100 or something and then
into ray of x
so something that's not known at compile
time basically
yeah okay
okay fine
but the other case for the structs the
case is um you know if you do struct
foo
uh this isn't quite correct c syntax but
you know if we just do something like
this
it's a semicolon i think
um
normally it doesn't destruct yeah
well at least it was i'm missing i'm
missing the type def that you need to
make this actually usable but but but
ignoring that the the two ways you do it
if you were allocating it on
the
the
it's like the
stack way
would be you just write um
foo you know
my object and then later you write my
object dot field one equals you know
blah blah blah etc right so it's just
you just write this and that just that
just says that you want to have it on
stack and then the heap you would do
you know
my object or you do
you must have it as a pointer foo star
you know my object equals
right
right i understand but for us
if you do something on the stack
what does it look like i mean how do you
you are
you're inside it looks identical it just
looks identical
okay
the only the only
substantive difference is that
you have to be a little aware of what
you're doing because you can't return it
like it'll crash your kernel if you
return it from a function
and it gets used but presumably we
detect that in the compiler and don't
let you return it well
it's uncomputable in general of course
you know
right i mean this is by the way right
this is also an issue with the two
pointer front pointer stuff above is
that right now you know we don't really
have any escape analysis stuff and of
course you know like tom was saying you
can't
it's fun you know it's ultimately
undecidable you can't you can't actually
you could call a you know an external
function and you don't know what that
does
so well right i mean there's there's
that case but but even in code that you
write just
code that you see that that you have you
you don't know what it does right i did
this by the way i had some there were
some ideas that that maybe a little more
time to get figured out with this this
unmanaged or managed or whatever it's
called thing which might resolve some of
that but um
okay so the issue here is
for this thing that is being allocated
on the stack
i mean sorry on the heap
but you might want a version that's
allocated on the stack as well
maybe that's too obscure so
i don't think it's too obscure i think
people are going to want that
okay
i mean i i
the only reason to do is for
optimization
yes
well but i think i mean isn't there also
you know tom isn't there a thing of you
can specify in the type declaration that
that when this thing is created you'd
like it to be on stack oh no no sorry
sorry no no no that's something
different versus value that's making it
a value not a reference thing you see
how is that different though like if you
write something like this
isn't this equivalent to the value
version yes well the what you've written
there isn't quite right because then you
would refer to the address of my objects
oh that's right
so then you would
if you wanted to you know if you wanted
to do effectively the same thing of just
i want to
you know i want to have the the speed up
of not having to do a bunch of heap
allocations
by setting this to be a value
yes value semantics right doesn't that
get you the same thing no no no because
because one is
you you you because one's in a dress and
the other is the thing you see
i mean
right but i mean i i'm just saying what
you've read
is sort of you know you've got the whole
thing there you could return that my
objects
from the from the function that would be
completely valid
and return the address from the function
right the question is why would you want
if you could do it this way okay the
value semantics way why would you
instead
why would you ever choose not to do that
instead to do the stack allocation way
because as far as i can tell the only
real difference is because
if you're passing it um you know if
you're supposing it had a thousand
elements then
you know everywhere you're using it in
your code it's taking up a thousand
elements well no no but but the version
that just has that's allocated on the
stack but has reference semantics you
already can't pass that anywhere because
it'll it's it's it's it's
just the memories
actually i guess you can't i guess you
know you can't
further down and they if you go further
down in the stack
in the stack and the stack of stacks so
yeah i guess it it is safe yeah okay
and you can return it so
you can't return it when the stack has
been unwound
because you can return it from this
camera you could return my object from
the function as it's written there you
could return it yeah because this is
just because c makes a copy when it is
it would copy it back
this is how
complex numbers for example
i mean this is this is the value
semantics that's because i've written
this in the value semantics way yeah but
yeah yeah so it's not a reference you
don't have an address if you do size of
this you have size of all the elements
rather than
you know a pointer all right so the
thing we've got here we got this
question of this name
of the con create compiled objects
yeah i think that's the main question i
think the stack thing
maybe it's worth having but it's
definitely a a
a more niche feature i mean it's not
it's a third argument or an option or
something like that rated on the heap is
is the main thing actually let me
suggest a name create type instance
isn't that what it is
it's going to be given a type
create an instance of a type
um
let me think about that it's slightly
confusing because there's an internal
thing that the top ver top-level version
of it is gonna have a different name but
the internal thing is called type
instance and has nothing to do with this
but but yeah um
uh
i mean
at some level everything has a type so
creating crate type instance is a little
bit like saying
create object instance it's like as
opposed to what you know
of course the instance is going to have
a type hang on hang on hang on the
virtue of having type instances there is
the first argument is a type
yes
and the create instance thing is
overloaded they don't need to give the
type it's a way of doing polymorphic
object creation see this is not this
thing is not polymorphic you see
you you have to give an actual type in
this
right because yes
so um yeah
i'm i'm promoting create type instance
now various people let's see richard is
commenting that this is like move
semantics i've never heard of move
semantics that's this stuff with the
value versus value versus uh
reference semantic stuff yeah
why is that called well i thought it was
called by value call by reference etc
where did it get a move
okay the motivation for stack
performance richard says
for the stack is performance what about
different evaluators allocators right
yeah yeah i mean that that's
reasonable
well yeah you mean like you mean you
mean like i would like to i've written
my own evaluator please use this one
um
well no this question i mean as
richard's pointing out linear versus
pool versus i mean how do you fit in the
the blocks that you're trying to
allocate all those kinds of things
because i know something right now it's
just we've made a choice i mean just as
malloc you know you can write your own
evaluator but if you just call malloc
it's going to just do something no we're
not we're we're calling it we're not
holding that which is
spent a lot of time making super awesome
optimizers
it has size tables and pools and all
this stuff in one
and
and it's consistent you can allocate in
compiled code and free in the kernel i
mean obviously that's useful you see so
yes that was very important i mean i'm
just saying that
you know i think that the
right the case of i in my particular use
case i realized that the default
evaluator is is sub-optimal in some way
and i've written my own about my or
sorry
i've written my own allocator or or i've
gotten my own allocator off a shelf
somewhere i think that's a pretty niche
yeah that's finished by the way down on
the livestream is commenting on the
following thing about stack allocated
versions of an instance being just type
of foo
sub value
field whatever
i'm not sure quite what the type does so
that's kind of what we have it's kind of
we have for the compiled expression
stuff
so so this is again again this is if you
define this low level you know c style
struct this is what you're gonna have to
do
but for compiled expressions
oh that's the declaration but i'm i'm
no no the way they compile expression
declaration does it is if i do this
right and i say it takes an integer 64
and a real 64. the way i instantiate
this secretly this is defining a struct
like this and the way you instantiate it
is just by doing this
but
right
okay
the point that that that uh
they're saying is is it's
type
just having
the full sub value thing of a type
specification there although we don't
really have that it will be a will be
like a typed object
of the type or typed as suggesting types
instance
well type type specifier is a higher
order
type
yeah like typed
right like suggesting typed instance or
type instance
type instance of foo
of that
although it has it has to be the
association um
yeah fine the association there that's
the payload or whatever arguments um
right but it could be funny because this
is a little array
the internal the internal thing that
currently does this is basically this
syntax but it's called compiled back to
you but it doesn't have an association
so uh but yeah it's a function
let's say the type instance of cra
um you know
um 12 for example would be but
i don't quite understand type instance
would be something yes that would be the
stack version of this because that just
is that that is that object in the code
but then what does it mean to apply it
to its fields or whatever well no it's
just that's just creating an instance
i mean i mean okay so you wouldn't you
wouldn't have this you just write that
and that has it uninitialized because i
think that the point is is that
what you're saying but you might be able
to say type instance the initialized
type that thing that symbolizes i mean
you could just as well i mean i'm just
saying this syntax is the same as this
because you could just as well write
this
you know without
the i'm not sure if we want to allow
that but if we're allowing on
initialized stuff you might as well just
write that i mean
yes but i'm just saying i think on the
heap whereas that other thing that type
instance thing would just return
a handle to the type instance right in
both cases though you realize that these
things have
references
yeah they're all reference objects
right well they're looking identical
they look identical and every function
you apply to them is absolutely
identical okay so then then question why
is it not just called
the that type instance of foo
just
represents
an instance of the type foo a blank
instance of the typhoo type instance of
foo comma
you know some some association would
represent a filled in instance of the
type foo
so this is exactly the same as crepe
type instance i know so i'm just
yeah
i mean unless you have to unless okay
i'm just trying to understand we don't
have to explicitly free it do we
there's no deleting okay so this is this
is this kind of is where we get into the
this business
so
okay
so
by default i think this should be set to
have automatic memory management and so
no you will not have to free it if
you're interacting with an external
program or in certain other cases you
will probably want to disable that
so that this is the raw struct in which
case it will not be memory managed in
other cases c arrays c arrays are just
not memory managed um and so you will
have to free those
um
so the way that
yeah i mean there are various
there are some schemes for how to deal
with that
um can we could we talk i'm getting
completely tired actually i mean it's
quite yeah i'm i'm late for something
else
but yes
what
i think when you say can i can we talk
you meant tom can we untalk
well can we talk another time
i'm
tired right
but but this is all very useful actually
how much further do we how about was
there a bunch more stuff in this agenda
not really so the main things are this
unmanaged stuff um then the return type
stuff we talked about briefly last time
which really just needs a name
and then the um
wherever it went the paclet stuff which
is probably going to be
i think we should we should talk about
that a bit what is the thing because i
was just having a big meeting about
pacquiao repository earlier okay well
we'll have a lot of spoilers that might
that might change you know tentative
spoilers i mean basically
it's something like this where
um
basically right now there are these
things called compiled components the
name is maybe up for discussion um but
basically the way it is is you know in
the paclid info file you can specify the
extensions that your packet provides
like oh i provide these symbols i
provide a library or whatever one of the
things you can tell it it provides is i
provide you know the graphs component or
whatever for for compile code
and and so
uh
right and that way when you write you
know function compile or when you create
a compiler environment you can tell it
by the way i need this component or
something like that but
that's sort of one aspect of it the
other aspect is that basically there are
these two you'd like to be able to
specify when you write a paclet
you know you'd like to be able to also
specify top level functions that you'd
like to have
you know available from the packet but
which are written in compiled code so
basically this is something where you
you sort of register various functions
that you'd like to have in your packet
and then at some point you call build
and that will run the compiler and it
will create some library and it will
basically you know
build your packet and then there's you
know ways of loading it and so on so
yeah
it's it's a big thing but for another
discussion
yeah yeah yeah yep
right
sounds good great stuff yeah oh this is
um
by the way for i mean presumably a bunch
of things are going to be in for
thirteen one is that a two seconds
one thing you're gonna be in point one
yeah why not i think pretty much
almost everything that we've talked
about here i think can be in thirteen
one yeah yeah that's quite soon
right
this is great
okay all right
thanks